well today is the deadline to file your
taxes big news in regards to tax relief
when it comes to working families with
kids
kirsten joyce joining us now with the
details
millions of middle and low-income
families across the country will start
receiving monthly payments
as part of a new fully refundable child
tax credit
these advance payments were included as
part of the american rescue plan passed
in march to provide relief for families
during the pandemic
the maximum child tax credit increased
from two thousand to thirty six hundred
for children under the age of six
and three thousand for children six
years of age and up
it also made the credit fully refundable
and turned
half of the credit into what will become
direct deposits right into your bank
account
here's the great news you won't have to
wait until your next year's tax return
to get that break
i'm announcing today that on july 15
and the 15th of every month thereafter
throughout the year
you will get deposited in your bank
account half of your tax cut at least
250 dollars per child each month
a direct deposit into your account
under the american rescue plan
individuals making up to 75
000 annually single parent head of
household filers making up to a hundred
twelve thousand five hundred and married
couples who file
jointly with a combined income of up to
a hundred fifty 000 per year
are eligible to receive the full amount
i'm kirsten joyce